tunisians appear to have little appetite
for parliamentary election
fewer than 10 percent showed up to vote
the lowest turnout since democracy was
established 11 years ago
it's a major setback for president
kaisayed who had hoped for strong
support in favor of reforms he
introduced in 2021
the new Parliament will have let's say
the government will be appointed by the
president who has Consolidated his own
powers in the last two years
as soon as polling stations opened it
was obvious people had stayed away gun
were the long queues waiting for their
turn to vote
I have hope things will improve and that
the new Parliament will save our
interest not the MPS personal ambitions
this election was seen as another step
in a road map president Syed introduced
when he suspended Parliament sacked the
government and introduced major
political changes more than a year ago
the national salvation front a coalition
of opposition parties boycotted the
election
despite the low turnout a defiant
president's ayed defended the election
as a crucial step to build a lasting
democracy
this is your historic moment don't miss
the opportunity vote so you can get back
your legitimate rights for justice and
freedom
an oasis of democracy in a region beset
by instability and violence Tunisia had
been run by a coalition led by the
conservative another party but
oftentimes consensus didn't work major
reforms were delayed progress slowed and
people's frustrations got worse
last year I say it stepped in expanding
his powers and limiting the role of the
country's independent Judiciary
opponents accused him of carrying out a
coup
the Arab Spring began here in Tunisia
galvanizing Millions across the region
to call for political freedom and
economic reforms but 12 years later
Tunisia looks different its political
landscape Changed by president kaisaied
who incest dissolving the Parliament and
changing the Constitution were necessary
measures to prevent a descent into Civil
War but his opponents say
the country is sliding into
authoritarian rule